and we're hearing about more
developments from Russia's National
anti-terror Committee let's go back to
Moscow and speak to Euler shapa valiver
you know what can you tell us
well actually we're getting reports
right now that Evgeni pregursion but
first let me uh tell you a little bit
about that so evgeny progression
actually replied to Mr Putin's
statements and uh he said that they're
not going to surrender that they they
are Patriots and they will continue
fighting uh with the system and against
corruption in the country as well so we
do receive some reactions some official
reactions on Putin's words here like a
foreign Ministry spokeswoman said about
Unity within the country uh former
Russian president Dmitry Medvedev also
said that the country has to unite uh
for the president well it seemed like
there is also a new form of expression
of loyalty to Vladimir Putin and the
Russian Armed Forces officials in their
social networks right the name of their
region with words we are with the
president and uh in his speech as we
remember Mr Putin has said that Russia
is fighting for its future and its
identity and the authorities of Russia
will not allow the country to be divided
they will protect its people he called
the situation in the country treason and
betrayal saying that any internal unrest
is a deadly threat to the state and the
Russian people and He also mentioned the
conflict with Ukraine saying that the
entire Western military machine was
directed against Russia and according to
him all Wagner's fighters who
participated in the Special Operation
Ukraine are heroes and now they should
not join the military Rebellion uh also
some telegram channels associated with
the Wagner group claimed that they were
actually clashes with the ministry of
Defense in the veronis region but uh
militaries and Military correspondence
write about the work of Aviation along
the M4 highway but we can't verify those
reports well the investigative committee
has launched a criminal case against the
Evgeni pregosian and and FSB appealed to
the fighters of the Wagner group and
urged them to detain pregocion and
earlier on the head of Wagner called on
his supporters to join the ranks of his
military company and sort out the chaos
as he called it a chaos in the country
saying that it was not a military coup
but that was a much of Justice
live for Moscow there thank you